une bien jolie finale côté dames c'est
après midi à roland garros avec le
sentiment quand même que quelque chose
vient de changer dans le monde du tennis
puisque l'imbattable l'incontournable
martina navratilova s'est fait sortir
par la jeune steffi graf 17 ans et des
poussières
elle était triste martina mais rien à
faire c'est fx est bien la meilleure
aujourd'hui sur le court central daniel
cazals a insisté ce ne fut pas une
grande finale car il y eut cet après
midi sur le central quelqu'un qu'on
n'avait pas invité
levant un discret qui gêna
considérablement les deux joueuses
maison du droit quand même à quelques
forts beaux échanges avec l'opposition
de style entre une martina navratilova
prenant le filet dès que l'occasion s'en
présentait et une steffi graf campant
sur sa ligne de fond attendant
l'adversaire pour mieux la juste et en
passing shot à ce jeu martin à aller ça
quelques plumes ne pouvant ajuster ses
volets ou ses smashs comme elle le
désire est si bien que steffi enleva la
première manche 6 jeux zakat en 37
minutes dans le deuxième set steffi graf
allait se montrer un peu moins précise
dans ses passing shot ce qui permettait
à martina de briller particulièrement à
la volée à 5-4 sur son service
l'américaine réussissait même une volée
réflexe qui lui donnait la deuxième
manche 6 4
dans le troisième set à 3 jeux partout
steffi graf allait perdre son service
sur une nouvelle montée au filet de
navratilova le passing shot de la jeune
allemande était facilement interceptées
par l'américaine sur son service d'un
ventilo vannes ne laissait pas passer
l'occasion après un excellent
enchaînement service volée de mener 5
jeux à 3 steffi graf aligné alors trois
jeux d'affilée pour mener 6 jeux à 5
réussissant une bien belle demi volée à
la suite d'une de ses rares montées au
filet mené 7 jeux à 6 martina
navratilova allait perdre la finale pour
la troisième année consécutive cette
fois sur une double faute
à 18 ans - une semaine steffi graf
devient la plus jeune gagnante du simple
dames
c'était vraiment un match très serré
après l'us open j'avais perdu 7-6 au
troisième set je ne pensais pas que nous
pourrions jouer un autre match aussi
serré
quant à martine elle s'est montrée bien
belle perdante
je suis très déçu parce que le match
aurait pu prendre une autre tournure
mais c'est puis à mieux jouer quand
c'était important
elle méritait de gagner félicitations
toutes les deux ont promis de revenir
l'année prochaine